sébastien meurant bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france alors on le disait
un bureau politique très attendu 1 ce
matin chez les républicains
hier soir dans une tribune publiée par
le figaro valérie pécresse bruno
retailleau laurent wauquiez ou encore
hervé morin se sont déclarés en faveur
d'une primaire ouverte regarder le
premier risque serait d'encourager la
compétition sauvage et les aventures
solitaires en faisant du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle le seul moyen
de départager les candidatures de notre
famille nous préférons ne pas imaginer
cette hypothèse qui nous empêcheraient
d'accéder au second tour alors une
primaire pour rassembler comme le
pensent les ténors de la droite vous
êtes pour ne doit pas comment on peut
faire autrement a vu les circonstances
c'est l'état de notre famille politique
à une époque où évidemment il y avait un
chef qui s'imposait naturellement à la
famille de la droite et du centre
ce temps là est révolu et d'ailleurs il
a évolué dans tous les mouvements
politiques et ne devrait crise de la
démocratie on a pu voir avec
l'abstention magie massive donc c'est
lors de cette dernière élection il crée
également des partis politiques des
mouvements politiques
on a pu de mouvements politiques
réellement populaire avec des centaines
de milliers d'adhérents
même si on peut constater récemment et
moi je suis président d'une fédération
donc d'une fenêtre du val d'oise qu'il y
a quand même une appétence malgré tout
et heureusement pour essayer de
réfléchir au sein d'un mouvement
politique pour un projet pour le pays qu
on ne peut pas faire autrement
une première actuellement d'ailleurs
c'est prévu dans les statuts des
républicains et les personnes qui
voudraient ne pas concourir cette
primaire être choisie par les médias par
je ne sais qui à mon avis sont dans une
voie sans issue
vous parlez vous parlez de xavier
bertrand puisque lui s'est déjà déclaré
candidat et il est contraint d'ailleurs
cette idée de primaires pour guillaume
pelletier le numéro 2
de votre parti xavier bertrand s'est
pourtant le leader naturel de la droite
regardez j'ai décidé de montrer
l'exemple de renoncer moi-même à toute
participation à une primaire en
soutenant avec force dès aujourd'hui le
mieux placé d'entre nous le seul capable
de battre emmanuel macron est de faire
gagner la droite
j'apporte mon soutien à xavier bertrand
alors xavier bertrand pam au vert dans
les sondages ces derniers jours votre
réaction à ces propos de guillaume
pelletier mais imaginez bien que si
chacun chez valérie pécresse et estime
que c'est m
c'est elle qui est la mieux représentée
si laurent wauquiez qui est le mieux élu
lors de ces dernières élections
régionales et c'est quelque part c'est
un côté un peu ridicule la question
c'est d'abord quel projet pour le pays
donc lors de ces primaires c'est
l'occasion de discuter de frotter sa
cervelle contre celle d'autrui comme
disaient les grands philosophes pour
faire aboutir un projet l'incarnation
doit être seconde selon moi et nous
avions eu donc lors des dernières
élections présidentielles des primaires
avec un président d'un ancien président
de la république avec des premiers
ministres et aujourd'hui on sera
incapable de faire cela moi je veux
juste qu'ils me semble plus important et
essentiel c'est d'avoir un projet pour
le pays et ce projet doit être établi à
la vue et au su de des français et
c'était les français qui doivent selon
moi le maximum de français dans le cadre
d'une primaire ouverte
et moi je vais plus loin que les
personnes que vous avez cité puisque moi
je souhaiterais que eric zemmour
d'autres personnalités de ce calibre
donc s'il y en a qui viennent a très
très peu puisse participer pour que ces
échanges soit d'un excellent niveau
intellectuel un idiot qui sont le plan
des idées et que les français puissent
se rendre compte que c'est dans cette
famille là de la droite du centre que
réside un projet qui permettra à la
france de sortir de ce marasme et de
ringardiser les autres formations
politiques qu'elles soient des
écologistes des socialistes et de sortir
de cette volonté de certains d'avoir
soit emmanuel macron soit marine le pen
au deuxième tour
moi je ne vois pas aujourd'hui comment
monsieur bertrand peut se dire qu'il est
les visions gaullienne et tout le monde
à cette vision la lune et plus partis ne
fait plus partie des airs nous au sein
d'une partie donc le numéro un de la
famille de la droite qui descendent ce
sont des républicains
il n'y a guère que laurent wauquiez que
robben retailleau qu'éventuellement
monsieur barnier qui pourraient
participer
donc le fait de faire une primaire
ouverte est élargi à des personnes qui
ont quitté et dans les conditions que
l'on sait notamment concernant monsieur
bertrand la famille de l air et bien
pour moi il n'y a pas d'autre solution
que cela pour pouvoir exposer un projet
pour la pour la pour le pays vous disiez
souhaité la participation d'eric zemmour
à ces primaires qui n'est toujours pas
un candidat qui n'est pas candidat
déclaré en tout cas pour le moment
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire pour vous
le cap le projet de la droite il doit
s'appuyer davantage sur son aile
conservatrice
le projet de la droite doit s'appuyer
sur une volonté de remettre le pays à
l'endroit
on a fait ça ce pouvoir a fait voter des
lois iniques sur les vins dits de
bioéthique qui ouvre des dérives
terrible pour le pays les français sans
ne s'en rendent pas compte
et il est là c'est pas une question de
droite conservatrice puisque vous aviez
personnalités comme si elle est gaz 1 ce
qui n'a donc la femme de monsieur jospin
vous aviez des personnalités comme josé
bové et donc on est très très très très
loin de la droite conservatrice sur des
sujets qui sont majeurs où tous les
repères ont été abolies par ce président
emmanuel macron dans ces domaines dont
sociétaux mais également ce président
était incapable de faire aucune réforme
pour le pays
je pense à la réforme de l'état je pense
aux réformes de la justice de la police
je pense aux réformes du millefeuille
territorial en fait c'est quatre ans
pourquoi quatre ans pour abaisser encore
le pays qui n avaient pas besoin
nous sommes sur le plan des résultats
économiques l'avant
dernier de la zone euro un pays où on
peut espérer pas me faire beaucoup mieux
dans que moi je pense que la droite et
le centre ont pour mission de redresser
le pays de reconstruire les tares de
reconstruire la nation et de
reconstruire la démocratie est cette
démocratie
avec aussi peu de participation aussi
peu d'intérêt des citoyens pour les
élections
il est bien content de la reconstruire
et le fait puisque les français
considèrent que l'élection majeure ils
ont raison cc d'élections
présidentielles de pouvoir débattre
longuement de pouvoir débattre de tous
les sujets avec les meilleurs esprits et
c'est pour ça que je me permets d'avoir
cité eric zemmour même s'il n'est
toujours pas candidat je pense que si
l'école du commandement et c'est
vraiment ça on recherche d'un président
d'un public digne digne de représenter
le pays
c'est l'école de la culture générale
c'est la culture générale et bien
mettons les meilleurs pour pouvoir
discuter d'un projet pour le pays et que
ce projet se discussion se fasse au vu
et au su du maximum de français
et là les médias seront forcés de
s'intéresser à la primaire d'un raté du
centre et ceux qui ne voudront pas
concourir puisque chacun évidemment est
libre de ne pas concourir
eh bien je pense qu'ils seront ils ce
sont des ils se mettront à pas et que on
verra que ils n'ont peur tout simplement
participer à un des échanges qui
permettront de définir un projet de la
projet pour la france c'est ce qui est
nécessaire et ce projet doit tourner à
la reconstruction de l'état de la nation
et de la démocratie
en tout il y aura un débat sur la
question de la réforme des retraites
puisqu'elle est toujours dans l'esprit
des manuels macron il rencontre ce matin
les leaders du patronat et des syndicats
voyez ce qu'en dit
françois bayroux le haut commissaire au
plan justement sur cette réforme des
retraites je pense que la période
électorale n'est pas favorable pour
faire passer à la va vite une réforme
le seul moyen de ne pas bloquer le pays
c'est de passer par un référendum
le président de la république s'il se
représente et les candidats à la
présidentielle vont chacun défendre un
principe de réformes et cela aura valeur
d'une orientation extrêmement forte
telle est votre position concernant la
réforme des retraites est ce que vous
rejoignez cette idée d'une nécessité
d'un référendum par exemple pour les
français et d'une réforme qui ne soit
pas précipité d'attendre notamment la
présidentielle
sur les retraites nous paraît anormal de
paraître cette réforme des retraites
avant d'avoir voulu une volonté forte de
de résorber toutes les toutes les toutes
les fraudes
vous avez essayé de travailler avec une
sénatrice nathalie goulet sur la fraude
les fraudes sociales et notamment les
fraudeurs en retraite
vous avez des rapports qui ont été remis
par la cour des comptes vous pouvez
consulter de 2017 sur des fraudes
estimées pour les centenaires algériens
marocains et autres à plus de 200
millions d'euros
moi je voudrais déjà qu'on s'attaque à
toutes les fraudes après les retraites
est une question évidemment d'un rapport
entre le nombre de cotisants et vous
seriez favorable à un allongement du
départ à la retraite
en fait ce qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
c'est augmenter le taux d'activité des
français et il faut pas pareil que des
retraites
et c'est sur la durée de vie des
français où on peut on est en décalage
par rapport aux autres pays ou en amont
on cotise moins on travaille moins que
les autres donc c'est soit on entendra
des semaines plus longue est alors moi
j'ai moi je suis pour la liberté
je suis pour qu'on ait un deux un nombre
d'annuités de cotisations etc en
fonction de cette année musée de
cotisations eh bien on est une une
retraite en fonction et si on doit
travailler 40 ans 42 ans mia est plus on
commence tôt plus on peut s'arrêter tout
terrain
et et 7 annuités de continuer à être que
de cotisation doit permettre d'avoir un
niveau de pension
pay plus évidemment on travaille plus
niveau de pension et supérieur donc
d'abord première chose pour moi c'est
vraiment s'attaquer aux fraudes
elles sont nombreuses et s est
absolument scandaleux de continuer à
payer des retraites indus après il faut
expliquer aux français qu'on ne peut pas
faire différemment que la plupart des
autres pays européens
aujourd'hui on a le niveau un niveau de
pension qui a des plus élevés un niveau
d'activité qui est plus faible et ce
n'est pas durable
mais néanmoins les choses ne sont pas
figées je veux dire si on avait un pays
qu'ils étaient capables de créer de la
croissance de résoudre le chômage
on a près de 6 millions de français qui
sont en sous emploi ou chômage
aujourd'hui sur les différentes
catégories a b c vous imaginez bien que
si ce chômage
on était capable de livrer par deux et
bien le programme de retraite ne serait
un problème qui serait beaucoup moins
prégnant qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui
donc la question c'est la création de
richesses donc il faut trouver en france
a les moyens de créer des richesses et
ça peut passer évidemment par travailler
plus et travailler plus longtemps
aparté année des milliers aujourd'hui
possible de faire des choses
différemment et en tout cas pas de
manière précipitée et là je pense que
monsieur françois bayroux sur cette
question là a bien raison de ne pas
vouloir allumer le feu pas comme vous le
dire john dit mais comme c'est de ce
pouvoir était incapable de d'anticiper
avec nous et rappeler la personne qui
était chargée de mener cette recette
cette réforme des retraites
lui même avait un certain nombre de
retraite et lé comportement qui pouvait
être très très très contestable donc ce
pouvoir a été encore incapable de mener
à pied de mener à bien ses traits de ses
traits forme donc ne pas de
précipitation n'est pas de précipiter me
semble une bonne une bonne chose bien
sûr 16e mixant présidentielle peu oui il
nous reste quelques secondes
juste jeu va vous entendre sur la
question la vaccination obligatoire
la situation sanitaire préoccupante ces
derniers jours avec le variant delta
quelle est votre position une
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants pour l'ensemble de la
population
quelle est votre position sébastien
meurant sur ces faits c'est bien tard de
vouloir soigner et soignants devoir de
avoir une obligation vaccinale décider
des soignants moi je pense que il est
très difficile aujourd'hui de convaincre
les derniers soignant non vaccinés et
qui doivent prendre maintenant les
mesures qui leur était qu'il aurait
fallu prendre il ya un an et demi de ça
parce qu'il ya un an et demi de ça on a
pu constater des clusters pas forcément
dans les hôpitaux mais également dans
les autres dans les maisons de retraite
et là maintenant nous savons comment il
faut se protéger donc le seul pays
aujourd'hui qui a l'obligation pour les
soignants d'être d'être valent d'être
vaccinés c'est une me semble-t-il
d'arabie saoudite je suis pas sûr qu'on
va se retrouver en compagnie de ce pays
donc je suis pas persuadé que ce soit
une bonne mesure parce que donc les
auront peu après les tendres vient aux
enseignants à toutes les personnes qui
sont en contact avec le public
l'obligation je pense que les français
n'ont plus confiance dans ce pouvoir et
les atermoiements sur les différents
vaccins me laisse penser que c'est ce
serait ce serait difficile voire
impossible d'imposer l'obligation
vaccinale aux soignants et pourquoi
après les soignants pourquoi pas après à
l'ensemble des personnes intervenant qui
a auprès des personnes recevant du
public
c'est très difficile compte tenu de
cette perte de confiance du pouvoir en
place
merci avoue sébastien meurant d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin sur rtl
france je rappelle vous êtes sénateur
les républicains du val d'oise